looking for a tense claustrophobic
thriller starring one of the best actors
in the business Amazon Prime video has
got you covered
7500 starring Joseph gordon-levitt as an
airline pilot who finds himself dealing
with hijackers Hurst touched down on the
streaming service the flick is winning
over viewers with its gritty tense vibe
and it marks another in a long line of
excellent performances by Levitt already
the movie is an international
co-production between American and
German studios with filming taking place
in Cologne Germany and Vienna Austria
German director Patrick Vollrath helm
the picture with Levitt leading a
multinational cast that includes
Austrian actor Omid Mima German actress
Island tehsil and French actress
I read eat a poem in case you're
wondering 7500 is the distress code that
pilots transmit to air traffic control
to let them know that a hijacking is
taking place
we have a 7500 contrary to what you
might expect Levites character Tobias
Ellis doesn't transform from
mild-mannered pilot to action hero movie
when the hijacking goes down he deals
for the emergency much as a real-life
pilot word lending to the movies air of
realism at the beginning of the film
Alice is getting ready for a routine
flight from Berlin to Paris he chats
with his girlfriend a flight attendant
and to make small talk with his captain
before departure as soon as the flight
is in the air though the situation takes
a turn for the terrifying when a trio of
hijackers attempt to force their way
into the cockpit
Ellis manages to lock himself in and
transmit the distress signal to air
traffic control but of course the
hijackers begin taking hostages
demonstrating the bay mean business when
he refuses to grant them entry 7500 has
received mixed to positive reviews with
even those critics who pun the film
conceding that Levitz performance makes
it compellingly watchable but those who
recommended the film were in the
majority praising it for its emotional
weight realism and the stylish direction
of Vollrath kevin cress for the Los
Angeles Times wrote 7500 is an
impressive technical feats that will rip
your lungs out for long stretches the
largely improvised tale of an ordinary
man in extraordinary circumstances
places you squarely in the gut-wrenching
position of its protagonists rather than
the over choreographed fight scenes of
most Hollywood movies the violence here
is clumsy painful and visceral quest
also noted an interesting facet of the
film's production its screenplay
consists largely of just the technical
jargon between members of the flight
crew with most of the additional dialog
improvised by the cast helping to
further Heights and the flex realism
estimated takeoff weight is fifty four
point eight tons blocks rule 7.2 tons
that gives us an extra fuel of 1.2 which
is around for 30 minutes Roger Moore of
movie nation appreciated that quality
and in particular admired Gordon
Levitt's approach to his character
writing there are no glib taunts threats
or macho one-liners gordon-levitt makes
Tobias believably human he gives us a
master class in screen acting in
close-ups and does that enough throw
that good enough to give us more pause
before booking that next trip negative
reviews have tended to focus and what's
perceived to be predictable plot twists
and the use of Muslim terrorists as
villain
which is admittedly a tired trope at
best but most critics felt that 7500
delivered the Gertz varieties guy large
wrote gordon-levitt a Mema play it for
all the emotional agony s worth their
performances together with the
economical expertise of the film's
construction keep 7500 cruising some way
above b-movie level surprising as it may
seem given how captivating his
performances gordon-levitt wasn't
actually the first and only actor to be
lined up to play the lead role paul dano
who will appear as a Riddler in 2020
once the Batman was originally slated to
top line 7500 but he wound up exiting
the role that due to scheduling
conflicts after the intended mid 2017
filming start date was pushed back
gordon-levitt then nod the leaden past
and the rest is history in the ends the
way things panned out was pretty perfect
and most critics feel the same
you can check l 7500 right now on Amazon
Prime video check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos but your favorite movies are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one